>>> A THIRD ROUND OF TALKS ARE
EXPECTED TO TAKE PLACE TODAY
BETWEEN RUSSIA AND UKRAINE AS
CIVIANS ARE DYING AS THIS WAR
RAGES ON.
JOINING US NOW IS THE ATLANTIC
COUNCIL FELLOW ON THE GROUND IN
UKRAINE RIGHT NOW.
HE WAS RIGHT OUTSIDE OF KYIV
WHEN THE INVASION STARTED AND IS
NOW NEAR THE ROMANIAN BORDER.
I KNOW YOU ARE AWARE OF THIS
VIDEO THAT HAS BEEN CAPTURED OF
CIVILIANS USING A WELL-KNOWN
UNOFFICIAL HUMANITARIAN CORRIDOR
OVER THAT BRIDGE FROM IRPIN
BEING KILLED.
I MEAN, THIS IS ON CAMERA.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS NEW
DEVELOPMENT?
>> IT'S ABSOLUTELY HORRIFIC.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY A HORROR,
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO CALL IT,
WHICHEVER LANGUAGE.
THE RUSSIANS ARE DOING VERY
BADLY AT TAKING TERRITORY.
THEIR LOGISTICS ARE TRULY
HORRIFIC.
THEY ARE NOT CAPABLE OF TAKING
TERRITORY OR WINNING HEARTS AND
MINDS, OR WINNING LARGE BATTLES.
IT'S DAY 12.
THEY SHOULD HAVE TAKEN KYIV NINE
DAYS AGO ACCORDING TO AMERICAN
INTELLIGENCE IN THE RUN UP TO
THE WAR.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING NOW IS WHAT
THEY'VE ALWAYS DONE IN PLACES
LIKE ALEPPO, BOMB CIVILIAN
POPULATION IN ORDER TO SUBJUGATE
THEM.
IT'S HAVING THE PREDICTABLE
EFFECT.
IT'S A TOTAL HORROR AND IT'S
TURNING EVEN THE MOST
PRO-RUSSIAN RUSSIAN SPEAKER IN
KHARKIV OR WHEREVER INTO A
UKRAINIAN PATRIOT IF THEY
WEREN'T ALREADY.
AND IT'S JUST NOT GOING TO WORK.
>> WE'VE ALSO LEARNED FROM OUR
JIM SCIUTTO REPORTING, ACCORDING
TO A SENIOR U.S. OFFICIAL, NATO
AND THE U.S. HAVE SUPPLIED
17,000 ANTI-TANK MISSILES, 2,000
STINGER ANTIAIRCRAFT MISSILES.
THAT IS A LOT.
AND MAY INFORM WHY WE'RE SEEING
WHAT WE'RE SEEING WITH WHAT
UKRAINIAN FORCES ARE DOING TO
RUSSIAN FORCES.
IS THERE A SENSE THAT UKRAINE
CAN KEEP THIS GOING ON LONG
ENOUGH WITH THESE WEAPONS TO
EFFECTIVELY DETER RUSSIA?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THE PANIC AND FATALISM OF A WEEK
AGO IS GONE.
I THINK 80% OF THE POPULATION
NOW THINKS THEY CAN GRIND
RUSSIANS OUT.
THEY ARE TAKING OUT RUSSIAN
TANKS AND BMPs AND AMPs AND
SUPPLY TRUCK LOGISTIC CONVOYS
OUT FASTER THAN WE CAN WATCH THE
TELEGRAM AND YOUTUBE AND SOCIAL
MEDIA VIDEO OF THEM EVERY DAY OR
EVEN EVERY HOUR, HALF AN HOUR.
WE GET ANOTHER VIDEO OF AN
ENTIRE BLOCK, ENTIRE CONVOY OF
THESE BOMBED OUT HUSKS OF FORMER
RUSSIAN VEHICLES WITH RUSSIAN
MILITARY GUYS HANGING OFF THE
SIDES OF THEM.
THERE ARE SO MANY OF THESE
VIDEOS NOW, THEY'RE NOT FAKE.
I DO BELIEVE THE REPORTS FROM
THE UKRAINIAN MILITARY THAT
THEY'VE TAKEN OUT 800, 900
TRUCKS, BMPs, 250 TANKS, YOU
KNOW, THERE ARE SO MANY VIDEOS
OF FARMERS PULLING AWAY WITH
THEIR JOHN DEERE TRACTOR A
RUSSIAN TANK OR BMP OR ARTILLERY
DEVICE OR EVEN SOMETHING BIGGER
THAN THAT.
THE UKRAINIAN STATE HAS EVEN
MADE A STATEMENT THAT THEY WILL
NOT BE CHARGING TAXES TO ANYONE
WHO CAPTURED ARTILLERY OR TANK
IN THE UKRAINIAN.
IF THEY SELL IT TO WHOEVER, THEY
WON'T HAVE TO PAY TAXES ON IT.
IT'S AN INCENTIVE TO GO OUT AND
CAPTURE A TANK, MAKE YOUR
$150,000, SELL IT TO WHATEVER
PRIVATE COLLECTOR AND YOU DON'T
HAVE TO PAY TAXES ON IT, AND
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE.
>> YOU WROTE A BOOK ABOUT YOUR
BELOVED ODESSA, AND WE HAVE NOW
HEARD FROM PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY.
HE BELIEVES RUSSIA IS PREPARING
TO BOMB THE CITY.
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING AS YOU
HEAR THAT?
>> I'M THINKING THAT I WANT TO
CRY, FIRST OF ALL.
SECONDLY, I'VE BEEN ON THE PHONE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET
MY RELATIVES AND MY FRIENDS OUT,
ANYONE I KNOW IN ODESSA WHO IS
MIDDLE CLASS OR HIGHER IS
ALREADY GONE.
ANYBODY WITH MONEY, ANYBODY WITH
CONNECTIONS, ANYBODY WHO HAS
WORLDLINESS TO TRAVEL THE WORLD
ALREADY GONE.
SOME OF MY RELATIVES, MY
IN-LAWS, YOU KNOW, THEY'RE
ROOTED IN THE CITY, THEY DON'T
TRAVEL MUCH.
FOR THEM GETTING INTO THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL HEAD SPACE OF
LEAVING IS DIFFICULT.
WE'RE TRYING TO GET THEM OUT.
I'M ON THE ROMANIAN BORDER.
I'M GOING TO CROSS INTO ROMANIA
TOMORROW, MEET THE WOMEN AND
CHILDREN IN MY FAMILY BECAUSE
THE MEN ARE NOT ALLOWED OUT.
MILITARY AGE MEN ARE NOT ALLOWED
OUT OF THE COUNTRY.
I'M GOING TO TAKE THEM TO A
BORDER TOWN IN ROMANIA, THEN I'M
GOING TO PUT THEM ON A PLANE AND
GO THE OTHER WAY BACK INTO
UKRAINE.
MY WIFE FORBAD ME TO GO BACK TO
ODESSA, BUT I GUESS I'M GOING TO
HAVE TO.
I'M ACTUALLY IN CHURNOWITZ WHERE
MY FAMILY IS FROM.
THE HUNGARIAN EMPIRE LIVES
BEHIND ME.
THAT'S A CERAMIC TILE OVEN
HEATING THE APARTMENT I'M IN.
I'M GOING BACK TO ODESSA TO GET
MY FAMILY AND FRIENDS OUT.
THANK YOU TO A HUGE AMOUNT OF
TREMENDOUS SUPPORT FROM
AMERICANS ALL OVER THE PLACE WHO
ARE GATHERING MONEY TO GET
REFUGEES OUT, FROM SAN FRANCISCO
TO BOSTON, FROM TEXAS TO NEW
YORK.
I'M GETTING SO MANY DMs AND SO
MANY AMERICANS WHO ARE OPENING
UP THEIR WALLET AND THEIR HEART
TO GET PEOPLE OUT.
I IMAGINE THAT SO MANY PEOPLE
HAVE GOTTEN THEIR WALLET OUT AND
WE'RE GETTING CHILDREN AND OLD
PEOPLE OUT OF ODESSA AS THE
RUSSIAN ARMY IS ABOUT TO COME IN
WITH ROCKETS AND MISSILES AND
AIRPLANES.
SO I'M REALLY GRATEFUL TO MY
FELLOW AMERICANS FOR SHOWING
THEIR BEST SIDE.
>> WHAT ARE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
LIKE WITH YOUR WIFE AS YOU ARE
GOING TO DO WHAT SHE'S ASKED YOU
NOT TO, GO BACK TO ODESSA?
>> YEAH, SHE'S GOING TO FIND OUT
ABOUT THIS FROM CNN.
SHE'S NOT GOING TO BE HAPPY.
YOU KNOW, MY WIFE AND I SPENT
HALF THE TIME IN UKRAINE AND
HALF IN FRANCE.
SHE'S A FILM PRODUCER.
THE FILM PROJECTS THAT SHE'S
BEEN WORKING ON FOR TWO YEARS
ARE NOT GOING TO HAPPEN NOW, SO
SHE SPENT TWO YEARS WORKING ON
THINGS THAT ARE NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN.
EVERYONE ELSE IN THIS COUNTRY
HAS BEEN BUILDING THINGS,
BUSINESSES, HOUSES, FAMILIES,
WHICH ARE NOW UNDER ATTACK,
OFTEN DESTROYED, OFTEN ARE
DERAILED.
IT'S A CATASTROPHE.
MY WIFE IS AN ACTIVIST NOW.
SHE'S HOME IN PARIS.
I'M EXTREMELY PROUD OF HER.
SHE IS GATHERING SUPPORT FROM
ALL HER FRIENDS.
SHE WORKS 18 HOURS A DAY
DIRECTING THE DIASPORA, THE
UKRAINIAN AND RUSSIAN SPEAKING
DIASPORA IN PARIS TO SEND MONEY
TO SEND HELMETS, TO SEND
MEDICINE.
SHE IS ORGANIZING PROTESTS AND
FILM PRODUCERS.
I'M EXTREMELY REALLY PROUD OF
YOU, MY DEAR, MY BELOVED.
I'M SORRY YOU TOLD ME I CAN'T GO
BACK TO ODESSA, BUT A MAN HAS TO
DO WHAT HE HAS TO DO.
I WILL GET A HELMET BEFORE I GET
BACK THERE.
BUT I'M REALLY GRATEFUL TO MY
FELLOW AMERICANS FOR SENDING SO
MUCH HEL